just a few months into 2023 Haley Beaver
admits that she's having a hard time
this year you betcha you betcha in the
wake of online drama with Selena Gomez
on social media it can really tear
people down the model gets candid on her
Instagram story my mind and emotions
have been fragile to say the least I
like to make jokes about how I feel
because sometimes it's easier than
admitting I'm having a hard time it
means something to me Haley confesses
that this comes after some of the
saddest hardest moments I've ever had in
my adult life the moments yeah there's
been a few I think my advice is to not
be afraid after weeks of rumors Haley
and Sal put on a United front last month
with Selena defending the wife of her ex
Justin Bieber who was receiving death
threats and hateful negativity amid
their alleged Feud I'm very honest
though in general in the aftermath Haley
shared on the gram I want to thank
Selena for speaking out things can
always be taken out of context or
construed differently yeah take for
example this Tick Tock from February I
accidentally laminated my brows too much
so after Selena shared that Kylie Jenner
entered the chat posting snaps of her
and Haley's eyebrows leading to
speculation they were mocking Selena but
Kylie quickly stepped in telling fans
this is reaching no shade towards Selena
ever and I didn't see her eyebrow pose
Selena also cleared the air writing
agreed Kylie Jenner it's all unnecessary
I'm a fan of Kylie I'm at that age where
I feel like that's what matters is
making sure I'm healthy and people are
happy that I love what else a resurfaced
clip online of Hayley gagging At The
Mention Of Selena's bestie Taylor Swift
on drop the mic Hollywood's top Stars
face off in a one-on-one rap battle full
of the meanest lyrics about a celebrity
since Taylor Swift's last album
Point Selena revealed she was pushed
push us on social media I'm too old for
this so but I love you guys so much
I'm gonna just take a break from
everything I'm very lucky that I have
the platform I have I always hope that
the people I'm involved with or support
me can just kind of spread love within
that back in her Instagram story on
Thursday Haley offers a supportive
message I know so many other people feel
the way I feel so just know you're not
alone let's keep showing up for each
other even when it's hard we're better
together
foreign